I'm starting off with some plums the
same mistake
hey I'm Alexis and I'm watching my
cooking fails from chef's out water it's
kind of cooking baking I think I'll do
two more minutes and see what happens
I am trying to microwave rust for lemon
bars and this was like one of the
hardest episodes I've ever filmed I
think I was like left in tears
afterwards I never use a microwave to
make food and microwaves aren't meant to
cook crusts oh no it's burnt
the good news is that there is some
color on the crust bad news is that
there was no good news it was all bad
news
it literally smelled terrible it smelled
so bad people were coming up towards the
room and being like is everything okay
here I mean it looks like garbage like
that is only usable it didn't actually
use that version but I just remember
feeling after this I was like this is
impossible
what am i doing so I would usually just
roast this really low and slow for a
while but let's see what happens if we
do I just want to say that I watched
someone do this and it worked so I
wasn't totally grasping for straws at
them in the microwave
I'm gonna try to make the polenta oh my
god and I'm just ignoring the microwave
water maybe the milk is bad idea in this
case but adding some salt I mean watch
like something is fishy here something's
wrong
[Music]
had intervene sorry smoking oh it's like
on fire I don't want to say this is a
disaster quite okay feel like number one
rule with cooking is don't leave the
stove don't leave what you're cooking
and I like number one role just like
fled the scene it was oh my god
so he'd already smelled bad from the
crust but this like legitimately caught
on fire and was smoking and I had to
pour water on it to get it out he was oh
my god it was awful after the garlic
catching on fire I was like I don't know
how I'm gonna redeem myself like they
they edited together the video to make
it like okay like it all worked out but
it was just I was truly like in tears
the end of the day I felt so bad I felt
incompetent I was like this is I just
made so many like rookie mistakes I felt
like I didn't understand how to use a
microwave it was it was rough I mean
microwaves are just like on a totally
different like power voltage and heat
source and every microwave was different
never cooked with one but like
microwaves are really not meant for like
cooking like they are great for
reheating food you can make things in
them but I wouldn't
[Music]
lying on our appliances and tools and
it's good to be like you know we can
make great food win fairly this was the
second episode of chef's out of water
and I made a three-course meal using a
clothing iron which mostly went pretty
well I'm making mini crepes on an iron
which took like three hours to do but
I'm also decided to you know because I
couldn't use other appliances to hand
with this whipped cream for the layers
of the crepe cake and for some reason
also decided to like porn and tire like
container of heavy cream in there what I
needed like maybe half a cup but decided
to pour like I don't know two cups of
cream so much cream so it was like
beating it and over and over and my arms
were so tired and I was just like what
am i doing I mean this whipped cream
looks really pretty oh it's so you here
the cast was so awful it was like it
tasted so terrible I put like so much
salt in there and I had just spent 20
minutes beating it by hand and I was
like what it was it was awful it was
awful it was awful it's just a rookie
move I was like going too fast I wasn't
paying attention I was like being cocky
it was like I got this beautiful whipped
cream we're just gonna it was like like
licking a salt block I should have just
tested that it was sugar it's like the
easiest thing to do and I was just
rushing
[Music]
so I've got some eggs here I'm gonna
pour some water over it and add a little
bit of acid after the first time used to
microwave and it went so poorly all the
commenters and my producer was like we
have to do it again Oh so we did this
episode I was making a three-course
breakfast with a microwave 30 seconds 2
minutes a minute a minute I'm gonna do a
minute it's just like inconsistent
that's why I hate microwaves it's like
inconsistent you don't know what's gonna
happen I mean it did kind of pump I need
to clean this up I mean the egg looks I
mean it did kind of poach but that is
obviously not a poached egg and it was
like I just felt so frustrated I felt so
frustrated
I was really confident about the fire
this was the finale of Chef Mehta water
and they surprised me by bringing me to
the Angeles National Forest like an hour
and a half outside of the city we were
in like our out of service like in the
middle of woods and I was so excited I
was like finally something I can work
with like a campfire this is amazing and
I felt so happy and I felt so confident
every episode asks what my confidence
level is with this like little graphic
and I was truly at a 10 like maybe an 11
well my fire is going and getting really
hot get it ready
I'm gonna start on dessert I'm starting
off with some plums I just added salt
instead of sugar to the plums the same
mistake I seriously don't know what's
wrong with me it's like the sugar was
right there why did I put them next to
each other I like assistant off to the
side so we had to like wash off each
plum in a bucket of water and then like
blotted try to get like any of the salt
out you know looking back is really
exciting I mean I think despite these
mistakes I feel really proud about the
food I made and the obstacles of working
with these weird appliances I like
pretty much overcame them even with the
microwave there was still like edible
interesting food you know I think what
the mistakes that I've made I think the
common thread is going too fast
and rushing and like not taking the time
which is you know just a common thing I
need to work on in life if I had to give
myself some advice I would say it just
like take your time it's okay to go slow
you don't have to rush oh yes
[Music]